I remember teachers like pulling a fast
one like that like tomorrow is movie day
everyone's like Yay because they think
it's like an actual movie and they play
like Gone With the Wind or something and
everyone's like what the [__]
[Music]
all right this has been circling the
news a lot because it's been a kind of
interesting topic where a Florida
teacher says she is under investigation
after showing a fifth grade class a
Disney movie with a gay character in an
AKA Strange World what movie is that a
new movie yeah it's a new movie I think
it went straight talk what's the
investigation and the teacher's in
trouble okay so basically in this movie
Strange World a spoiler alert the main
character is gay and he uh it takes a
long time for him to like try and come
out to oh geez
come out to his father be okay with it
and everything fast so that oh so that's
the actual plot of this one that's
that's one of the themes of the whole
theme the plot is is realistically uh
Ant-Man Quantum Mania and uh Avatar it's
the same [__] where you just get lost in
the world and then you have to figure
out your way out it looks like a regular
thing but the very very Dynamic thing
about this particular one is it the main
character is Ashley gay and he like has
a boyfriend or like wants to like share
with his father you know what I mean
that that's the Dilemma yeah okay so
this Florida teacher shows this movie
have you seen this movie I have I have
seen it you like it it was all right was
the gay storyline no to me it was like
another like literally have you seen an
Ant-Man quantity I tried watching the
first five minutes and I turned it off
it's also terrible uh but it's like the
exact same movie like you just go into
it's called Strange World you go into a
strange world yeah and then you [__]
discover the world like is it Disney
quality you know Disney projects are
usually pretty I can see how um for kids
of that age you know how like a Disney
quality when we think of like Disney
like Pixar movies like toy store and
stuff like that adults can still watch
it and feel like this is a really really
good one yeah I think this one was all
right
um but I'm I'm guessing for is it Pixar
I don't know if it was Pixar that's why
can you check yeah I'm just kidding the
last Disney who's the director of it I
think Pixar is different than Disney
yeah I think the last picture was uh
Moana I think moana's a banger bro see
that's a good movie yeah it's not it's
not Pixar Moana was a bang if this
teacher was showing this movie and
constantly was just like guys that
character gay okay like over and over
yeah that's kind of that requires
investing but if it's like again that's
one of the themes of the movie it's not
necessarily like everything is about
that everything it's very like father or
son and it's multi-generational so it's
like the father's got father-son issues
with his Dad aka the grand Paul oh
they're all gay all the way up no just
just in general that your father-son
Dynamic and then the generation I think
would have stopped at some point
so the sun has an issue with his father
and it's just like there's many many
themes is this like a conservative
private school or something
dude everyone in Florida is always
getting mad about it's in Florida so it
has to be right it's a it's a Hernando
County's Winding Waters K-8 school oh
Hernando County does it have a DeSantis
Wing
meatball Ron Wing
So in the video
um of this t-shirt she like went on Tick
Tock about this she said I'm the teacher
that's under investigation with the
Florida Department of Education for
indoctrination for showing time to get
some followers I mean it's as plain as
if when she got hired they were like
don't be Jean gay stuff to the kids and
she did it that it's like just teach at
a different school then yeah yeah she
explained that she played the Disney
movie to a class which was only
partially full after a day of standard
standardized testing she also said she
had previously signed permission slips
from all the parents allowing the
students to watch a movie rated PG
dude you know where I can see a problem
let's say that I'm in sixth grade or
what grade is this Fifth Fifth Grade
okay let's say I'm in fifth grade right
and I'm and I am gay and I don't I'm not
ready to come out but then when she
shows that movie everybody's [__]
looking at me isn't that what they did
to you in class didn't you talk about
that story yeah well that's why like I
feel like that is kind of messed up in a
way like if you're not ready to you know
because we had friends growing up that
you knew they were gay but like you gave
them their like space and you're like
hey I'm not gonna make a big deal out of
it but then this kind of like puts Focus
like for people to be like hey you
probably like this movie huh classic
kids yeah it's like that is kind of a
maybe some kids aren't ready to be
talking about it my question would be to
her is is like what why did you have to
show this particular movie like what was
the reasoning behind moana's way better
dude you know that's the thing because
if it was a movie that went a new one
you know but if it wasn't that popular
and it went because I think you
mentioned it kind of went almost
straight to whatever video that would be
my question is this if she had an agenda
yeah that's that's to me then yeah
that's kind of like I have issue with
but if she was just like oh it's the
latest Disney movie and she was genuine
and honest about it and that to me I'm
like okay that's that's cool but if she
had an agenda like there is that one kid
that I think needs to come out and wants
to come out and I'm Gonna Make It Happen
try to pry him out yeah yeah I'm gonna
show this movie and everything's gonna
everyone's gonna love the kid it's gonna
be great yeah then it's like all right
you know what no you you know yeah you
should show a rush hour or something
yeah yeah you can never go through race
relations amazing Rush Hour did it man
race yeah Rush Hour number one probably
what another good movie would be uh Step
Brothers Schindler's List maybe because
it's a long movie oh my Lord long movie
it's educated I was gonna say Shanghai
Noon they make color film now
but it is up there the hang of a movie
though like you showed us on fifth
graders I think it'll change how they
look at the world you know you know it
just reminds you of like there was a
point where uh the class that I was in
this is when I was a kid there was a
choice of either to watch I think
Cinderella or something or Fiddler on
the Roof and like we had feeler on the
roof at home like in my house and I was
like yo we should take Phil and roof
that movie's freaking tight and then so
they picked Phil and roof and everyone
was pissed at me because it sucks is
that the one with Barbra Streisand I
don't know it's just I don't know
I mean it's not for kids
it's a musical and it's like three and a
half hours but I liked musical as a kid
and I just didn't know that that was
like an unpopular choice and I convinced
everyone we should vote on that and
everyone was pissed at me I remember
teachers like pulling a fast one like
that like tomorrow is movie day
everyone's like Yay because they think
it's like an actual movie and they play
like Gone With the Wind or something and
everyone's like what the [__]
which is why it was a big deal when they
played Romeo and Juliet from 1968. I
didn't see that until high school though
I was eighth grade and you're like oh
there's boobies here damn I never saw
that that wasn't I don't think that was
anyone's first boobies they saw on like
TV Kate Winslet dude Titan I feel like
there's mad gay or movies you can show
kids that just sounds like it's a good
movie where the characters happens to be
gay and it kind of helps the plot right
like this is what wait like to get out
of the Strange World style above holes
same thing with American me dude
everyone's embed American History X
oh remember Ving Rhames was in Blood In
Blood Out
yeah
he's also in Pulp Fiction that gets uh
yep another moment they should be
playing Pulp Fiction in k through eight
fifth grade low-key Pulp Fiction is a
great movie dude I think you gotta show
kids movies like that now like this
because I think nowadays kids are like
hella soft so you gotta show them some
edgy [__] you know bro you know what do
you guys think you guys should teach
kids yeah when I was like I think I was
already like first year Community
College the teacher in a theater class
showed Papillon what is that it's a
French film it's pretty freaking crazy
but it's about a guy that like goes to
like a prison on an island and he tries
to oh I have seen that it's heavy as
hell yeah and there's like and his
friend in the prison is like this pretty
ass like dude who's constantly trying
people are constantly trying to take
this dude's butt dude it's crazy do you
see any penis do they get them no yeah
they I think they do get them but I
think he like sacrifices himself to for
the for the escape plan or so it's crazy
heavy but then I was like dude watching
that like really taught you a lot
there's a crash course kinda though I
think some kids I think nowadays some
kids need to watch this about booty
grabbing well because it's the crazy how
shitty your life could be yeah that and
also the because it's I think it's like
a true story or maybe based on a book or
some [__] but like he the whole movie he
basically formulates this amazing plan
to escape and they get all the way like
off the the island and they reach like
the actual other land and the whole
thing was like set up where they just
let him get that far just so the this
the um the boat that would rescue him
would just get paid by the jail yeah it
was like a bit so it's like
heartbreaking he like does this perfect
plan gets there and the guys just takes
him right back
yeah it's it's crazy you need Taco Bell
after movies like that yeah why so you
can throw up everywhere
I guess you could waste your money dude
but that's a movie like that's a good
movie to show kids like maybe not the
things that things don't work out yeah
yeah and just like what's a less version
don't go to jail a good moral dilemma
movie would be like uh is it Centipede
Human Centipede yeah I still need them
you said that was a documentary that's a
good moral dilemma movie you know yeah
yeah which which uh
what's the thing is like do you do you
pull your head out or do you pull your
butt out or do you both or I feel like
the if you had to pick a position I
think you gotta be the head totally the
top position yeah the very front oh yeah
yeah yeah the very front the middle
sucks yeah I don't watch the movie oh my
God no you shouldn't watch that so
basically people are like sewing this
guy is sewing like imagine sewing your
mouth to his [__] and then from there
sewing his mouth to your [__] so it's
a human centipede whatever he eats and
digests you eat his [__] when you [__]
it he eats it I feel like he's doing
that and you throw up you're vomiting no
it's like a it's like a crazy doctor
kidnap these people and did it to them
it's like a fever dream of you and Bart
on a JK session you guys probably have
like made that joke yeah yeah in like a
writer's room and they made a movie out
of the way I mean they made like three
of them didn't they yeah or that's holy
[__] yeah I think there's like three
like a Trilogy now yeah there yeah I
think there's three because it was a hit
I'd rather watch a Sharknado dude oh
play Sharknado for the kids you so many
of those that's just great because it's
an Ian Ziering movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
we just need to see more of him from
90210 Fame which I am currently watching
from episode one same here right it's
amazing which one 90210 Beverly the
original Beverly Hills downtown it's
incredible I can't believe it
[Music]
thank you